foreign
[Music]
well happy Thursday everybody Welcome to
the data science hangout if this is your
first time joining us here today it's so
nice to meet you thanks for spending
your Thursday with us
I'm actually calling in from the posit
office nobody's here with me today but I
have this nice view of the water
yeah but if we haven't met yet I'm
Rachel Dempsey a host the data science
hangout and Lead customer marketing at
posit
this is our open space to chat about
data Science Leadership questions you're
facing and getting to hear about what's
going on in the world of data across
many different Industries and so we're
here the same space same time every
Thursday so if you're watching this
recording on YouTube later
you can add it to your calendar with the
details below
but together we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming Community for
everybody and so we love hearing from
everyone no matter your years of
experience titles uh industry or even
languages that you work in
so every week I'm joined by a different
leader here from our community who joins
us to share their experience and answer
questions from you all
so to let you know how to ask questions
first of all it's totally okay to just
listen in if you want to but there's
also three ways you can jump in
to ask questions so you can raise your
hand on zoom and I'll be here
looking out you can put questions in the
zoom chat and feel free to just put a
little star next to it if you want me to
read it or else I can call on you to ask
the question live
and then lastly we have a slidolink
which Tyler will share here and right
when I said that thanks Tyler where you
can ask questions anonymously too
well with all that thank you so much for
joining us here today and I'm so excited
to be joined by my co-host Mike Lopez
the mic is senior director of data and
analytics at the NFL National Football
League and Mike I'd love to have you
introduce yourself maybe tell us
something you like to do outside of work
too and and share a little bit about
your role thanks Rachel and thanks to
everyone a positive for for organizing
these uh it is an exciting time to be in
football data
um and we just have a lot of questions
that we have to try and use
sort of naive or Advanced models for
because there is so much about the world
of football that we are just starting to
learn um my background was I was a high
school teacher uh turned PhD student
turned assistant professor at college
and at that point uh the influx of
football data became apparent the league
started getting next-gen stats which is
each player wears a pair of RFID chips
and their shoulder pads and you sort of
went from an NFL data history where
every game had 160 plays so 160 rows of
data which everyone was sort of
analyzing locally on their laptops so
now a world where we have this tracking
data both RFID based and then now even
video based and it's it's just hard
there's just a lot that we are learning
and trying to figure out so my job is to
organize a group of really intelligent
young data scientists that are helping
us and helping the league make better
decisions awesome thanks Mike and
something you like to do outside of work
too
uh
on our heart our preseason starts
tonight and um we and I I sort of now
realize that from now until the end of
March most of my spare time is going to
be keeping an eye on what happens and
everything related to the NFL
um so I got my my spare time was over
the summer I I have three young kids and
so hanging out with them is really how I
spend my spare time
um but tonight that is now done with an
eye on the NFL game that's on the
television so watching football that's
what you do in his spare time yeah yeah
we it's uh it's a nice side gig that's
great well Mike I know there'll be a lot
of questions coming in from everybody
shortly here
um but just hearing that initially about
how you're using data from the RFID tags
on the players I'd love to just
understand a little bit more about what
that process looks like and how you
ingest that data what you do with that
data just kind of walking me through a
little bit of that process so the the
league has I would say two data
warehouses of sort of systems of storing
data uh in the early 2000s that's when
the leak initially started building a
lot of the SQL Server that the clubs
still use and that we would still use
um that would be your traditional game
stats so if you play Fantasy Football
you know the yards caught by a wide
receiver or the quarterbacks uh uh yards
per game or whatever that would be that
would be your traditional game stats
um in 2015 was when the league first it
might have been 14 or 15 I wasn't uh
with the league at that point but that's
when the league started collecting the
player tracking data and they had seen a
catch on on other sports and it was um
driven by the Media Group out in Los
Angeles and so you know if the base game
stats are stored in New York the media
data is stored and managed by zebra and
the next gen stats team out in La we
ingest it there there are a couple ways
that the league gets it uh one is you
know using an API the second is there is
a SQL Server that that now is dedicated
to organizing and managing that data
um one of the unique things about the
tracking data is that it really sort of
changes your your data Pipeline and how
you organize and manage your code
because you used to be able to just sort
of load every NFL game play-by-play
whatever it has
and analyze it right for the model uh
make a graph now you you have to be a
little bit more uh articulate about how
you're doing that I don't know if
articulate's the right word but you have
to be a little bit sort of be
forward-thinking a lot of times what we
do is just sort of fit it on a play
right if you want to figure out was the
wide receiver open don't try to do that
on every play that wide receiver has
ever done just try to do it on one play
and identify a way of
whatever metric you're creating or
looking at openness for that wide
receiver and
doing it on that play and that that
takes a lot of time because you're
probably the first person to think about
your level of ranking that openness or
whatever and there's you know we're
doing a lot of things that lead to
increase the awareness of football data
and to give people the code so that they
can build uh their their new work off of
it but it's still new
um and then once you've done it on that
one play then try to do it again right
try to write a function to do it on the
game
um and then obviously extract it to all
players in all games and all that stuff
takes time so that's kind of how you
know the traditional you know you would
be an analyst in the year 2012 or 13 and
you you download csvs and you'd analyze
all the plays at once now you you have
to delete a little bit more cognizant
about how to do that just because of the
size of the tracking data thank you it's
really helpful I see a ton of questions
starting to come in here Devin I see you
asked one in the chat do you want to
jump in and I can ask the question if
you want to jump in with more context
feel free but the question was what kind
of decision making is your work driving
at the league level versus the money
ball team versus Team decision making
and they Devin said thanks for powering
my fantasy leagues as well so uh uh we
we are primarily interested in what
happens on the field and if it happens
in the field we're hoping to measure it
um and in the sense that that's how
close are our games how exciting are
they
um what are the trends and how teams are
calling plays and how players are
playing and how coaches are coaching
um we do a lot with our officiating
group uh trying to help them make better
decisions uh and then also both the the
sort of on Deal decisions but also the
training we work with player health and
safety on making sure that the rules of
the game are sort of the best match
between uh you know keeping the player
safe making sure that their equipment is
is as sort of top-notch as it can be and
then also going back to the rules like
what are the best you know whatever we
talk about a rule of the game it's it's
driven by does it make the game more
competitive does it make the game safer
can our officials officiate it does it
keep the game exciting things like that
so we try to organize a lot of our
um you know sort of support for the
league around a lot of those questions
um the teams make the decisions to go
forward on fourth down they make the
decisions to to challenge a play uh to
start a a quarterback or to draft a
certain player
um but a lot of what we're trying to
help with is that there are new tools to
help with those decisions um there's new
metrics that we can help create uh
there's new data sets that we can
provide them
um and ultimately what they do with that
is is obviously up to them I know you
just touched upon the the Health Data
but Geraldine I saw you had a question
about that do you want to ask a a
follow-up there yeah because when I
asked that question you were mostly
talking about tactics and plays Etc so I
was wondering
um do you guys also analyze players
Health stats around things like
um whether or not they get concussions
from impacts or dehydration or is there
like a separate team that deals with
that so as part of the NFL collective
bargaining agreement with the Players
Association the league doesn't analyze
that data themselves but there are two
third parties
um that that do two companies that we
work with a lot iqvn biocore are their
names and they're both really good from
an epidemiological side and an
engineering side at looking at how do we
you know what are the trends uh in the
injuries what are the you know both
rates of concussions or injuries or
missed time injuries or leg strains how
those change over time as athletes have
gotten faster and the teams are passing
more and things like that so that's
those are collaborations that we're a
part of
um it's the specific raw injury data is
is not something we we touch on a lot
only in the sense that you know when it
when it comes time for you know changing
the punt player the kickoff play or you
know the rules around how to protect the
quarterback you know it's never just a
health and safety question it's a you
know health and safety and an
officiating question or and a sort of
competitive question about if this is
going to make our games closer or more
blowouts or less exciting or less
tradition things like that so a lot of a
lot of the way that we try to work with
those types of questions is you know
like how does how does this impact the
entirety of the game and uh you know the
other aspect that I think is really neat
about where football is now is that it's
not just the game data it's also the
practice data and so
um you know most clubs have performing
scientists that work with trainers on
you know managing player load and uh
sort of optimizing player performance
from uh you know I think both a
performance and an injury side
um and and that's not stuff that we're
allowed to help with but we do know that
that a lot of clubs are going down that
route
um Greg I see you had a question in the
chat too do you want to jump in here
yeah sure uh thanks Michael for being
here today I actually got a chance to
see you speak at the University of
Denver back before the pandemic which
seems like a lifetime ago at the sports
analytics conference so
um I was just wondering if you have any
thoughts on how transferable
uh analytics skills sports analytics
specifically are across leagues right if
you if you build up experience with
baseball or basketball
how does that transfer to football or
other sports I know some of them are
more emerging than others yeah I mean I
I honestly I don't think you can be a
great Sports data scientist without
really having a sense of what's going on
in other sports
um so I would say it's really twofold
one is this the skills themselves are
transportable um if you can code
tracking data in football you can code
it in baseball you can code it in
basketball Etc it might take you a
little bit of time to get up to speed
but the specific uh functions that
you're writing or the specific ways that
you're transforming the tracking data
into
metrics that you can communicate with a
coach that that you can do in any sport
right once you can do it in one
um the hard part is being able to do it
in one so I think that's that's one area
the second one which is is really maybe
just as important is what are the other
sports doing what are they looking at
you know it's it's you know one recent
thing that's caught on to a lot of folks
in football is that baseball teams no
longer
draft a player and then send the player
out there and the player performs or
doesn't perform they're now doing things
in training to maximize the player's
launch angle or their exit velocity or
their swing path because they think that
they can take a player and help them
improve using using data and I don't
think football has always been that way
I think you know the the you know maybe
corollary would be you would have a
quarterback and throw the quarterback
out there and they'd either complete the
pass or miss it and maybe you could get
a new offensive coordinator but maybe
now you could be thinking about you know
where is the quarterback holding the
ball
um what is their path to throw it is
there something that we can do uh that
sort of the maybe the corollary of a
swing in baseball
um so that's one example that that isn't
certainly the only example but I think
it's sort of a combination of both the
hard skills Hands-On keyboard stuff that
if you can code you can code and if you
know Sports you know I think that's
that's going to certainly transfer but
then also in a way awareness of what are
other leagues doing what are the metrics
that they've come up with
um you know I think it's it certainly
helps on the data science to have that
background and that skill set because
there's just so much out there that the
NFL can learn from other sports and and
I do think
um specifically given some of the
competitions and the work that that the
football has done the last couple years
you know other sports are now learning
stuff from football too great I
appreciate that thank you very much Mike
we talk a lot about community and the
data science hangout and I I think the
Big Data bowl is an amazing Community
initiative that that stands out to me
um and I was wondering do you see this
initiative happening in other sports or
other Industries now and do you have any
tips for people who are trying to do
something similar
um and it might be helpful to just
explain what the big data bowl is too so
I one of my weaknesses is I hold grudges
and so I used to always get a little bit
irritated with some well-known uh Sports
conferences and organizations that would
um maybe run hackathons or share data in
ways that you know as an academic and as
somebody who supports reproducible
research maybe didn't have those same
values and so when I started at the
league I was pretty steadfast that I
thought the league could do a better job
of sharing data and
um you know one of the ways that we've
done that is through an event called the
big datable
um and it is it has a couple purposes
one is let's innovate in football and we
can be talented all we want as a league
office and and whatnot but there's only
so much that our group can do and the
next gen stats group can do there's just
a lot of other things that and sort of
you know the idea being that there's
just a lot we can do and if you share
data people analyze it so you know the
the quote from Field of Dreams is if you
build it they will come you know if if
you share the data they will analyze it
you know especially in sports data so
um that's that's one of the main reasons
we did it we also you know have the
motivation where we have this complex
data set that no one's ever looked at at
least this was our initial philosophy in
and if that's how we feel that's also
how the two NFL teams feel and you know
when you work at a league office you're
in some ways in employed by the 32 teams
and so we're doing it for them we're
doing it to give them a pipeline of
analytic staffers that they can hire to
go answer their own questions and one of
the really neat things is and I've sort
of hinted at this is that this is this
is an opportunity for anyone to come in
and analyze and it really levels the
playing field uh in the sense that
um you know before when you would hire
in in sports data you know you might
look at GPA or you might look at where
the person went to college or you might
look at
um uh maybe where they interned last
summer now you're looking at their code
right you're looking at uh what they
built you're looking at what is their
level of thoughtfulness in the questions
and the way they communicate the results
which ultimately that's how you're
evaluated when you're on a team right if
you're on a data science team and that's
your job is to build interpretable
metrics and to communicate those
um and to do a good job of validating
your models and things like that that's
that's what the big data bowl is all
about so
um we've seen a lot of one of the neat
things is that now people you know are
copying football and that was never a
place where football was before there
was the big data Derby and horse racing
uh there was a big data cup
um which staff leads put on in hockey I
think there was like now a fantasy
football one
um and it's it's it's pretty humbling to
know that uh that's that largely started
with uh you know the NFL sharing data
and being open about it so uh we're
we're certainly open to to more League's
doing it
in terms of advice
um the the
number one thing that we found is that
the crowd-sourced metrics are always
better than anything we'd ever come up
with ourselves and
um the more thoughtful and uh sort of
I I guess
um uh sort of thinking forward about
what people will analyze I think
companies will get the most out of it
like we've had competitions that have
immediately turned into metrics that are
shared on air and
um you know if our our 2020 competition
was on rushing yards and within maybe 11
months from the contest ending he
watched the NFC title game which has you
know maybe 30 million viewers they're
watching a metric that came from our
competition
um and that that's sort of a a really
exciting aspect of that competition and
so the better questions you ask the
better answers you'll get
um but I think overall you know we've
certainly found that the the crowdsource
approach has really helped that's
amazing I was just sharing in the chat
last year's winners actually spoke at a
a posit Meetup so if anybody wants to
save that and and check it out too
um you I see if you've had your hand
raised for a bit here do you want to
jump in sure uh hi Michael thank you for
being here I have one question so what
type of data are you using for the
analysis uh the tabular structure data
or instructors are like images or
recording from the game directly if the
data are unstructured how do you process
them before you can use them for
analysis and modeling yeah good question
I would say we've with each passing Year
we're getting the structured data
but I think the league has done a pretty
good job and when you're at a league
office we have a large number of data
Engineers that help that ensure our SQL
tables are are clean and easy to read
from
um I would say most of it's pretty
structured in the other reality is with
player tracking data at least in the NFL
because it's RFID based it's very
accurate and so it's it's a tabular
format in fact if you go to our big
datable site you can download it as a
CSV and it's a big data set but it comes
out clean
um that's not necessarily the case with
maybe some of the newer data sets we'd
be getting into if you talk about like
video tracking which would be like
taking from an image and then trying to
look at player location what one of the
ways that football is going is that we
have RFID tags on all 32 NFL teams and
all the players and all the games
however those players come from a pool
of college players the NFL can't make
college players wear those same RFID
tags and so when you want college data
you either have your traditional stats
or you got to use video based data and
so a lot of that video based data on
college players
um is stuff that is a little Messier and
so that would be where you would have to
extract it from Imaging and things like
that there are companies out there that
do that
um and and it's it's sort of I don't
know if it's an arms race but I I do
know that NFL teams are really
interested in those skills because of
the way that you know before you would
have to have
a dozen Scouts go out and watch videos
of the team's Northeast and the
southeast and the and all over you'd
send Scouts and teams still do that but
now if you can get some of that Insight
by coming up with an algorithm that can
take the data from the video and turn it
into a nice usable format but can
certainly save you some time and maybe
get you some insight you weren't getting
otherwise I see so many great questions
coming in here
um I'm just trying to sort through some
of them but Lisa I see you had a
question a bit earlier on Mike's
transition from Academia to the NFL do
you want to jump in sure yeah
um I'm Lisa
um I was just curious about how you made
the transition from Academia to
working for the NFL and how you think
that academic experience was helpful
and then maybe again this is probably
selfish but like how did you sort of
Market that academic skill set I think
the best part about the most helpful
part about being in Academia is that you
are evaluated and I was at a small
liberal arts college you're evaluated on
your teaching so you have to be a good
teacher right I was a you know a tenure
track assistant professor and you know
evals would come in and when you weren't
doing a good job communicating to your
students
um that's not it you know that that's
you know that's gonna that's gonna ding
you whatever so
um I think that's the most helpful skill
set is that my job was to uh take
um statistical methods and distill them
down to students who are learning it or
you know I I was I've been teaching R
for maybe or you know something some
software for a decade but when you do
that you know in 2020 or whatever I
couldn't be teaching the same stuff I
was teaching in 2010 because software
was entirely different so you also have
to sort of keep up to date and I that's
kind of a lot of what we do now like our
job is to communicate statistical
results or methods to folks that aren't
statistics experts um now instead of
students now it's Executives
um and and we are
you know one of the things that we are
constantly working on is what do we what
do we show how how much is too much when
do we lose them how many plots is too
many plots you know do they need to know
the ins and outs of our models
um and whereas in you know when you're
teaching you know you really need to
communicate all the ins and outs
certainly we don't do that now
um but I think there's a lot of the
experience that was most helpful was
teaching and communicating results
um we don't do as much writing
um you know I don't have as many
research papers maybe as I used to would
have
but now for better for worse I spent a
lot of time making you know
presentations and I think a lot of
that's the same approach where you're
trying to take what you've learned and
distill it into a uh a template that
others can understand
um I started in 2018 when I worked at
League office maybe uh doing one
PowerPoint deck every couple months and
now you know for better for worse I just
I have to do that a lot because I have a
really talented group of data scientists
that are coming up with so many cool
things and
um you know I I am now helping them
curate you know material to share with
Executives and uh you know there's like
I mentioned at the start there's sort of
a lot that we can we can do and uh you
know trying to figure out how to
communicate that is is goes back to that
experience in Academia where you're
writing a journal article or you're
writing
um a summary of your work so
um that's that's where it's it's been
most valuable and I also think
um one of the cool aspects about where
we are now is that you know it there's
just still a lot to learn and that's no
different than being in Academia where
you know you're an expert in something
and you're trying to build the next tool
where you're trying to to build the next
model or the next paper and and there's
um you know I think it's not that
uh you know I like to often refer to our
work as we just we have a laundry list
and sometimes our job is to just start
at the top what's the most important
thing we can do and that's not much
different when you're in Academia and
trying to do the same thing so great
question and I don't know if I answered
it right but that's that's where I would
think yeah that was great I took some
notes so thanks of course
thank you can we stay on this topic for
just a bit here when you were saying
when you were talking about the
communication skills that have
transferred over I was curious if you do
have certain tips for us for
communicating to Executives or what
you've learned in many of those
presentations you've given yeah I mean
we've tried and failed a lot I mean
there's things that I've pushed for
we've felt strongly about that other
word people were like you know
um and then there's other things where
maybe I didn't feel as passionate about
and then suddenly maybe every maybe the
presentation got shared a lot more
widely and I read about it the next day
on espn.com so I it's it's hard to to
really know like
um I haven't kept a spreadsheet of like
what's worked or what hasn't uh in terms
of communicating results I think the
we have to have good data visualization
if we don't we just we can't do our job
um and I I think I spend probably and my
team would probably complain about how I
do this but like I probably complain
about things that I I if this was a
student paper that like I probably
wouldn't right because I have to make
sure that the work that is being
presented is as clear and concise as it
possibly can be it can't be confusing it
has to have the right annotations
um the stuff that has come out in ggplot
in the last couple years and also in GT
with like the sort of visualizing in
tables has been really helpful in that
front because for a while
like we would have to make tables in an
old school format right or I'd have to
add annotations in PowerPoint because
you know you couldn't code that so
that's that's probably the most
important thing is is your your viz has
to be top-notch
I also and this just comes partly from
experience partly because I played
football in college and my dad was a
football coach and I grew up watching
way too much film
but the more closer you are to the
subject level matter the better you are
at your job
um it doesn't mean that you need it for
all roles you can be a great coder and
and sort of learn that skill set along
the way and I mean football is in some
sense a complicated sport
but in the other anybody can learn it if
you try to learn it right so it's it's
not like it's too far away from from
somebody to learn
um my mother-in-law complains that it's
too hard to learn but but I would say in
general like you you can figure this
stuff out
um but a lot of the things that we do is
we just answer their questions and um
I I think the the sort of
second part of communicating that
resolved is sometimes we are answering
the questions that we know they're going
to ask before they've asked them and I
think I I think the best presentations
we give are the ones where they're
asking a question and then I just click
next and it's on the next slide right or
they ask a question and I say yep it's
in the appendix click a couple slides
forward and say here it is because you
have to anticipate the questions they're
going to ask you have to sometimes we're
collecting data before they've asked us
to collect data
um because we can tell like we hear
something in the media or we hear
something that uh they're asking in the
replay room or the coaches are asking
and we're like all right we're gonna go
build this because they didn't tell us
to go collect data on quarterback slides
but we now know that quarterbacks are
sliding more than ever before we know
quarterbacks are the most important
position of football so last year Andrew
Patton basically LED an NFL data
collection process in quarterback slides
because we knew that when we got to the
off season somebody was going to say hey
how are how are quarterbacks sliding and
it's like actually we have that because
we went out and collected it um so I
would say that's it's combination of
great database and then also being
um purposeful and sort of Forward
Thinking with with the questions that uh
people are going to be wanting to ask
that's great thank you so much Mike
uh Sanjay I see you had your hand raised
a little bit ago do you want to jump in
here
yeah hi uh I I was curious when you said
RFID tags were used to track players and
so what all data did you collect uh
apart from just tracking the players I
mean is the speed direction what all is
captured just was curious to know yeah
so it captures the XY coordinate data
two-dimensional we don't get their
height
um the tags are uh like the size of your
thumbnail and they fit into the player
shoulder pads
um and some players don't even know that
they're wearing them uh they turn on
whenever they go on the field you could
you could watch players in the sideline
if you wanted to uh wouldn't recommend
it but
um you know then the the league takes
that data they share from the XY data we
get their speed acceleration because
it's two chips we also get their
orientation
um that's all curated and sent out to
the teams um from the league office
um so you know you could watch NFL and
you'd see like fastest players or you
know fast acceleration speed you could
get change of Direction you know from it
without too much effort so that's the
type of thing that that you would get
from this data and do you have RFID in
the ball also yes yeah good question
yeah uh there's an RFID on the ball
um with players I would say it's it's
accurate usually to within a couple
inches the ball is maybe you know has a
a larger margin of error maybe closer to
five or six inches
um and then with all of it with both the
the 22 players the ball
there's also RFID tags in things on the
sideline like the pylons and the chains
I don't think there's much use uh in
those but at least um you know has been
collecting it
um and then it's all at its uh frames of
10 10 frames per second right so
um you know you a given player a play is
seven seconds long you're gonna get 70
observations of that player on that play
and you could animate it to sort of
follow them around you also get their
Data before the snap and after the snap
it's just a matter of what you find most
useful Aaron I I think you had a
question related to that about the ball
too do you want to jump in here I think
the question was kind of about like
officiating and let's see Aaron said
I've always wondered why can't a Tracker
be placed on the ball to determine when
it crosses the plane for a first down or
touchdown uh so is that something that's
being looked at yeah and I think
geraldine's question is is similar um it
is being looked at there are a couple of
differences that I think matter a lot
one is NFL stadiums are enormous and
there's a lot of player overlap on
almost every play and so the cameras
have to be further away unlike tennis
where they're right on the field and
unlike maybe a VAR decision in soccer
where there's two three players maybe
right in a tight space arguably they're
a lot more so the technology that you
can see in other sports is is a little
bit more complex to apply to football
um in my now six years there have been
several attempts
um some gaining more traction than
others to do video based spotting
um uh it is a challenge
um and the current accuracy uh margin of
error of the of the football itself
using the chip in the middle of the ball
um can't can't replace uh the sort of
on-field spotting for a couple reasons
one I mentioned the margin of error you
know it it
you know if if you're saying the ball is
here but then you look on the film and
it's actually here it's really difficult
to justify that to a viewer at home you
know while you're making a first down
decision or a decision on the goal line
um and I think the second part there too
is the the ball spotting process the NFL
is based on the tip of the football
without
totally changing the construct of the
chip in the football we don't know that
and the chip is in the middle of
football
it's been tried to put multiple chips in
then you're sort of messing around with
the mechanics of of how that feels at
the quarterback and we don't want to do
that
um so you know there are video based
attempts my intuition is within a couple
years uh there will be use cases of it
that you'll see on air
um where uh the sort of technology is is
helping the the process of squatting the
football
um but it's it's not as easy as as sort
of maybe it appears in the other sports
and I also think we're
where the other aspect for us is that
pace of play is really important
um
in the sense that tennis can have a
break or soccer can have a break to look
at this decision and maybe the ball
isn't in play the second the ball is put
down the ball's in play there's no uh
other than the couple stoppages for
replay or or in between Downs
they're uh in between like a fourth down
uh and a punt play or whatever there's
there's no uh
example of sort of saying pause hold on
we're all going to wait right we just
don't have that time coaches want the
ball to move we want the game to be
three hours or so and and that sort of
continued Focus means sure you know
there might be a tool out there that's
going to get us to the exact right spot
but if it takes three minutes
you know that's that's not a that's not
a trade-off I think the league would be
making thank you
you see Jared had a question and you put
the star next to it so I'll read it but
Jared asked um how does someone get into
the NFL space as a data scientist to
help improve player safety and
performance so I I think there's a
couple of ways one is I mean there's
there are I mentioned iqb and biocorp
but they are two companies we work with
a lot and they're they're specifically
targeting
um you know things like the epidemiology
of injuries return to play uh injury
Trends based on on how teams are are
playing
um the equipment you know safest helmets
safest cleats safest shoulder pads uh or
uh the sort of characteristics within a
play uh that you know the the
orientation of of of a player uh limbs
that could lead to injury so I think I
think they're they're sort of things
that are specific to the injury side of
things that that are part of it then
there's also the maybe more performance
side which is all the teams want those
same questions answered and they have
you know just like you see the next gen
stats player tracking date and games
they get catapult data in practice or
there are other companies besides
catapult that do it does it but catapult
is probably the biggest one so you have
the same data that you get on your own
players in practice now that's not data
that that the league office would get
but if you're on a team and you can sort
of identify like listen this player has
had two or three really hard days in a
row maybe that comes with an increased
injury risk of a hamstring straight or
something
um I'm just I'm not necessarily making
that up but that's hypothetical right so
those would be the things that that you
would get into is thinking along like
what happens within a practice and how
to make sure that that player that put
forth a certain load that traveled a
certain distance
um that ran at his high speed for you
know 10 minutes which is maybe a lot or
three minutes which maybe isn't a lot
like how are they going to perform the
next day because ultimately the job of
teams is to win games and you win games
when your players are healthy so the
coaches understand the value of this too
so it's it's sort of a level basis but
then also on a more micro level the
teams are also looking into it thank you
Nick I see your hand was raised uh just
a few seconds ago do you want to jump in
here yeah sorry sure
um coming off you here hi everybody nice
to talk to you
um so my question kind of revolved
around I guess communication
um of of what you're finding and just
kind of having some like a personal feel
and read on you know football
personnel and staff so you know I know a
lot like the old guard guys might be and
folks in general might be a little bit
resistant to analytics and just kind of
the philosophy I was wondering and I
know you kind of mentioned like you're
doing more
PowerPoint presentations and talking to
people like how are you getting people
to kind of buy into analytics as a whole
how can you take your you know the
modeling that's the math and turn it
into actual advice but also from a
perspective that like is digestible for
football coaches that are Personnel
whoever might be working with you in a
way that they can you know use it accept
it and you know feel better about it
because kind of around the football
space it seems like the word analytics
is a little like a stink on it if you
know what I mean yeah I I haven't had a
lot of pushback like there hasn't I've
been I've been here six years there's
not been a single meeting where somebody
was like I don't want to see your
results or I don't care about X Y or z
uh I mean I mentioned earlier that there
are certainly times where I've thought
the league maybe could have done this or
a certain team could have said hey we
think we should prioritize this more and
maybe that hasn't happened
um I think a lot of it comes back to uh
we're not trying to answer different
questions that they are we're trying to
answer the same question they are and
we're just trying to put numbers to it
um and and you know there are lots of
examples where we just get a sense of
the questions that they're after what
they're interested in and we say here's
here's what we're thinking and I also
think we're you know I think we do an
appropriate job of pushing where we need
to push him and also saying sometimes
like listen I mean there are a couple
examples of random projections we've
been working on the last week where
sometimes we we've just said honestly
like we're giving you a projection for
something for some time
but I I wouldn't even really trust it
like I I personally don't trust our own
model right because there's too many
uncertainties that too much noise in the
system so I think we're also we try to
balance like when we we push and
um one of the advices I got from
somebody I think in in hockey a couple
years ago is I was asking that person
why their team didn't do something
and I it was like okay you know in
hockey it was a specific thing that I
thought teams could do to gain an edge
and and their point was uh this analyst
that I I talked to is that they look at
their role as they have a certain amount
of times that they could really push and
sometimes you you do it and sometimes
you say like listen I think my team
probably could increase my chances of
winning by this but there's something
else that uh comes with it that maybe I
don't want to it's not necessarily it
moves the needle only this much and it's
not worth it so I do think our team also
tries to be a little bit purposeful with
how we balance
um when we are saying like hey this is
something we should change or this is
something we should do because you know
we only get so many cracks at it and
um you know there are times where I
think hey we could really improve our
decision making here and there are other
times where I would say like Hey listen
I can give you a number but you know go
with your gut it's probably not going to
be that far off so
um I think our team is pretty smart
about sort of adding all the caveat
thoughts in the Stars just sort of say
like hey the asterisk right like hey
take our take our results with a grain
of salt like so many things are
happening in football teams are changing
the rules are changing that you know
assuming that that maybe this is going
to hold or that this is the best way to
do it is is not right but then other
times we try to really push for things
so it's kind of a balance of that it's
really helpful feedback
listening to like all the different
pieces of like data you're working with
or problems you're looking at solving
even some things that people haven't
asked for yet how do you prioritize what
your team's working on
I I don't have a great answer there
um you know like I I a lot of it is
honestly like wolves uh we have a
meeting in a week or so with some
Executives and my last slide is here are
six things we can do this fall tell me
where you would prefer we spend our time
um so that maybe that's kind of part of
is just getting a read on it uh you know
we're not a uh we're not totally obtuse
to what we hear in the media in terms of
what people are talking about because of
clubs
um you know it's a weird it's weird to
be in a public-facing industry but if if
clubs leak it uh
some media organization it's a non-zero
chance it makes it makes it way back to
our our group
um you know like last you're familiar
with football one of the things that
that last year started early in the
season is is teams would do what's
called a push quarterback sneak where
you would have quarterback lineup and
traditionally they would sneak forward
now you you put somebody behind them in
like two or three people are pushing so
similar quarterback slide through the
process we were like let's collect this
data because we saw it on pro football
talk in week two or three and it's like
if we don't collect it they're going to
get to the end of the year and complain
about it and it's going to be like oh
crap we should have measured this so
it's like okay now we gotta measure it
so it's just kind of being in tune with
what's out there uh the what we're
seeing on the field I mentioned I know
Rachel you asked what I like to do for
fun
you know I watch football for fun but I
also watch it knowing that whenever
something happens like sometimes there's
going to be a question we need to answer
Monday morning how often does this
happen is this getting worse
um and addressing that you know we we
deal with a good number of questions
from the clubs and from teams
um sometimes from an education
perspective but then also sometimes from
a
uh you know complaint perspective where
they think they're being uh uh there's a
perceived slide against them so uh just
trying to be a little bit aware of
what's going on and for us honestly
that's just
paying attention and watching thank you
uh Kayla I see you had a question a bit
earlier as well about the types of tools
they use do you want to jump in here
uh sure yeah I think I asked a question
about if most of this work is done in
Python and R are there any particular
packages if so or if that code is mostly
internal or if there's any other kind of
like software typically used in NFL
sports and analytics yeah a great good
question we
um I would say we're more on the r than
the python side but there's it's it's a
kind of a decent mix
um I've asked this to NFL team staffers
and one other I think good point that is
just sort of uh it exists is that teams
are hiring more and more so there's more
and more folks with our python
backgrounds going to teams
when I started I want to say that there
were maybe 70 or so data scientists
data scientists being a a catch-all term
here
um folks that were using football data
to try and help the team on the field
um maybe 70 or so and I think the most
recent list is we're somewhere around
130 or 140. so within the last five
years teams have basically doubled their
infrastructure on the football data side
um and I of the of that group you know
being familiar with a lot of them you
know uh our team probably knows uh the
majority of those those folks I'd
probably put it about 70 30 R versus
python
um and that's probably where our team
sits
um you know internally
um that's not
you know certainly there are uh I think
right now most postings are like you
have to know r or python
um you know a good number of managers
are probably more comfortable in R
um because of of the you know where
football data has been but that doesn't
necessarily mean that that that it's any
better
um and then I also think there's a
growing number of roles for people that
know neither but know what football data
is
so and like this would be like your
Communicator type role so folks that
maybe are really up to date with current
football metrics and maybe have coaching
experience or playing experience and
they want to be the translator they want
to be the person that is going and
saying hey you know I I can't fit that
neural net model but I know you can and
I know what it's going to give me as a
result and this is I think what's going
to help this coach or this uh assistant
GM or whatever
um so I would even say there's there's
even a good amount of room in in
football analytics for non-coders right
people who
um you know have some ability to know
what's going on in the background
um know a little bit about modeling and
know what the strengths and weaknesses
are well maybe not being able to do it
on player tracking data
um but also having that ability you know
you really have to know football right
to sort of get into that role and not
every team has them but
uh you know if you stay up to date on
the big datable and on next-gen stats
and on on sort of public-facing research
you can provide a lot of value to your
team right in terms of identifying
trends that are meaningful and maybe
trends that that you would want to
ignore it's really cool what what would
that role be the translator uh I mean if
if so for example you're an offensive
coordinator for a team and you want to
build a Scouting Report you want to
build a dashboard that says here's what
the opposing defense is going to do each
week
um there are lots of data scientists
that could do that
a good number of them especially the
ones that have spent the last four or
five years in football tracking data
might not know the names that your team
is using for what that opposing defense
is running right they might be able to
separate Man From Zone coverage but they
might not be able to separate cover two
from cover four from cover six or they
might not be able to understand the
strong sideline bagger for the weak side
linebacker and so now you need somebody
to sort of say like okay this is what
the coach is looking for this is what
this term is this is what this blitz is
and then your job is to code it all
right and to sort of work with that
Communicator to to make to help that
um I guess I was just curious like what
that title is like how do people find
those kinds of roles uh I would a lot of
them would just be like analysts or even
like quality control coach
um like Seth Wilder from ESPN on Twitter
has a really good link um I'm sure
somebody can can find and put in the
chat football all sports analytics
careers are like this there's a bunch of
different names for people that are
doing the same stuff
um and it's it's kind of weird like my
title is director of or senior director
of football data analytics right there I
could be senior director of football
analytics research or senior data
probably not a senior data scientist
anymore because I don't code as much but
you know summer analysts summer data
scientists some are you know whatever
and and uh there's not exactly one you
know perfect name for it um but yeah
it's probably an analyst type of role
um but it is a lot of times like
uh football coaches know a lot and
they're using data even if they're not
telling you they're using data right
they're gonna
they're gonna tell you that they're
going to Target the left cornerback on
the other team because they turn their
hips too early well you could probably
use an analyst to go figure out when
they turn their hips too early what does
that mean right and so a lot of times
you're just trying to communicate to be
that
um be that line because you know
unfortunately or fortunately like
that offensive coordinator might not
have all the time in the world for this
this uh this person to to advise them on
it so that's kind of where you need some
of the translators well thank you
um George I see you had a question in
the chat a few minutes ago do you want
to jump in oh yeah thanks
um so yeah I was just wondering this is
something I always think about whenever
I'm watching a sporting event is you
know how do I get
my organization to report at the level
of of what I see like the NFL or ESPN or
any in-game commentator reporting on the
kind of analytics that come out of their
mouths I'm just in awe of and it's you
know historical sometimes it's like well
the last quarterback who did this was in
1978 and he had like blonde hair and
went to this college and I'm like
I mean first of all like I don't even
think that's relevant but the fact that
they could pull that out of nowhere in
10 seconds is pretty impressive
um I've tried doing that in my field in
HR in the past
um
and that's always sort of the bar that I
have but I you know I'm just curious how
how does one go about even trying to
achieve that that level of of Analytics
it's it's a it's almost like a research
team and the NFL does have a research
team that they before every game they
provide the media with an enormous
um you know basically like a a folder
right of all the things and it this is
automatically generated using you know
uh you know various tools right of all
the things that are applicable to these
these teams
um and it's almost like scouting reports
uh that you would see of like a baseball
player or a football player like and so
when a wide receiver catches the ball
the commentator is able to go and say oh
well this is interesting he was you know
caught the you know hired the highest
you know Red Zone Target rate of any
tight end last year right and a lot of
it's not because they've done it it's
because somebody's you know sort of hand
got to them we don't do a lot with it um
that maybe that's maybe certainly more
on the media side and
um but I do know that that's you know
the research and media team's job is is
to prep basically a portfolio for them
to pull from
um and I do think one of the things that
they're they're balancing is how do I
take a lot of the new metrics that
nobody's ever heard of versus some of
the old things like you know everybody
knows a blonde hair is right like that
they could you could you could pull from
that that maybe wouldn't make as much
sense so
um that's a that's kind of where I think
football date is now is how much is too
much and what what is a reasonable thing
to give our audience
um maybe an area we don't deal as much
with but but it is relevant to some of
the research they get I realized I
missed a question over on slido so I
want to make sure I get to some of the
one of the anonymous ones but it was
you're gonna have to help me with this
acronym does gate g-a-i-t analysis of
the players have any impact on their
performance and what are the kpis that
you generally look for for players
potential impact so we've we've tended
to stay away from some of the
performance metrics
um and I think that's what git would be
um and so I wouldn't be able to to know
as as much there I think the the weird
angle we would come at performance would
be like how does the league set policies
or rules for a schedule or for practices
that allow players to reach the mobile
performance so we've done a lot of
research on for example uh what is the
impact of playing a team that just had a
bye week the previous week each team
gets won by a week of season if you're
the Jets and you're playing the Giants
and the Giants I've had two weeks of
practice
um maybe is that what type of Advantage
does that provide you on the field
um so it's a different performance angle
um you know like another ones would be
like back to back to back road games or
uh you know travel advantages right it
was a different type of uh performance
thing but it I think that's probably the
closest to the thing that the league
could control ultimately you know for a
lot of legal reasons you know we're not
as in tune with some of the the
performance stuff on the team side
um at least the league office but I do
know the teams are obviously interested
in it well thank you
um Brittany I don't think we got to your
question yet do you want to jump in here
I think you had a oh you unmuted I'll
have you ask it
yeah so
I know that with the introduction of the
RFID tags I'm sure that there's a bunch
of new data points that you're exploring
that previously haven't been explored
but also I'm sure that there are maybe
changes to like rules of thumb or
heuristics around already existing data
points that maybe are coming into play
now that you have a little bit more
specific data can you talk through how
you've been kind of evangelizing those
new and or maybe different than expected
things and how you've been getting
buy-in from your business partners
around that good question
um
uh We've we um and I can share a little
bit of this but we we because they they
shared it um this past offseason but one
area was the sort of stuff I was just
mentioning is that we did a lot of
research on what I would call Scheduling
inequities and uh basically how things
that the League sets uh impact game
outcomes and there were a good number of
surprising ones where things that I
think most people would perceive as
having a big impact on a team's chance
of winning the game maybe didn't matter
as much
um and so you know the scheduling team
mentioned that when they made their
schedule this year they they took some
of our advice to heart
um and a lot of that honestly was just
trust right I think we had to do a
really thorough job of looking at all
possible metrics that they thought they
might want so they didn't say go look at
X Y and Z it's we sort of thought from
our football background what are the
possible ways that anybody out there
could ever you know see an on-field
impact of these things
um and you know when we presented it was
it was thorough it had every possible
angle and and I think because of uh that
approach
um where it's sort of saying like Hey
we're not going to give you one thing
and say all right we're done we solved
it it's going to be we're going to give
you a bunch of different ways of looking
at it uh a couple different outcomes
um a couple different time points uh
we're also going to be acknowledge our
limitations and things we don't know
um so for example you know it might not
be the case that teams that are playing
three Road games in a row in the NFL
lose more often
but it is the case that if you're on a
team and you play three row games you're
away from your family for three weeks
and that doesn't just mean that we can
go through teams on the road for you
know three four five six weeks in a row
because that's going to have other
impacts that that maybe we're not
measuring so it's not a great answer for
me but it's honestly it's just trust
right it's it's building up a repertoire
of of trying to look at a bunch of
different things in a bunch of different
ways
there it isn't it's very rare I hope for
my you know like I said I have a great
team
we're almost always saying yes like can
you also look at this yep we'll do it
right sometimes maybe it's like I don't
really think that's going to matter but
honestly it doesn't matter they think it
matters so let's go find out and so a
lot of it is just sometimes just sort of
saying yep yep we're going to look at
every possible angle and try a bunch of
different things okay I know that this
hour is always the fastest hour for for
me of the week it's gonna be rapid fire
maybe two more questions at you if
that's okay
well actually this is a quick one Travis
asked have you ever lost in fantasy
football uh fantasy football is very
noisy you could be the best fantasy
football player in the world and if
you're in a team with a league with 10
players you you probably didn't
improve your chances much more from like
10 to 20 I've lost plenty we also have
very strict restrictions about what we
can and can't play so I'm gonna just
note that I used to play a lot more than
I am allowed to now
I see okay one one other question for
you then um
we'd love to hear what's something that
you're most excited about as you think
about the year ahead oh gosh
um
wow uh I think it doesn't have to be
like the biggest thing maybe it's the
first thing that comes to mind for your
team
yeah I I think the General State of
football is in a really good spot uh
last year we had the lowest margin of
victory since I think 1932.
um the game itself a lot of the sort of
analytic driven Trends I saw a couple
questions in the chat about these teams
are going forward on fourth down more
often uh teams are uh coming up with
more creative offenses all of that has
led to a more entertaining football
um I mean I don't think anybody has ever
turned on a football game and they're
like oh this is going to be awesome I
can't wait to see this punt play
um so in in general like the things that
are happening to football is making it
more exciting to watch and I do think
that that's created a you know it's
always been an entertaining product but
it's really at its peak so I think
honestly the the sort of trend for the
game itself is is in good shape
um and you know that that I think is
continues to make me excited about the
season there's
um it's it's always the case that
because you have a small sample size of
games you know we have 17 games
surprises are gonna happen you're going
to see new teams that that weren't in
there and that's always been a part of
football
um but I just think it's it's a fun time
to be in a sport where a lot of the
trends are are really improving uh the
entertainment product of the league
absolutely well thank you so much Mike
for joining us today and and sharing
your experience with us all and thank
you all for all the great questions
there are a ton of questions here I'm
sorry if we missed anybody's I'll try
and go through and see what we missed
but have a great rest of the day
everybody thanks and I left my uh email
in the chat if anybody has any
follow-ups or concerns or you know as a
student or a friend that wants to get
into football data
um you know please please don't hesitate
to reach out
that's great thanks so much Mike
have an awesome rest of the day
everybody bye